you get a phone call from somebody who
wants to book a ticket to take you to
New York and you've some crazy guy is
running a program called the New York
Institute that wants to put together
like a dream team of computer graphics
people was that the next big step in the
in the career yes after I graduated the
reality is nobody wanted to fund
computer animation to make any sense no
just a bad idea in particular none of
the film companies wanted to write so he
couldn't see it no they couldn't see it
yeah this was it it wasn't that it so
much they thought was a bad idea was
like it wasn't even on the radar it was
irrelevant to what they were doing right
they certainly didn't think in terms of
R&D or development right so Alex sure
who's the president of the New York
Institute of Technology wanted to fund
it he went out and talked with various
people and he ended up hiring me to
start a lab in in New York out on Long
Island out on Long Island of all places
yes is where it's essentially where
computer animation like really got its
start
yes we're going Island New York Long
Island New York where Long Island was it
Westbury in Westbury yeah where the
music festival occurs the Westbury music
fair and some punch oh yeah so you're
talking like an hour from Manhattan or
whatever yes yes right so deep in Long
Island yes you get in the city when you
need to but yeah it's not that deep
actually we're not that far out of right
take the LIRR yeah so so nice place to
be
yeah very bucolic mmm rabbits out on the
lawn and we we brought in some great
people so Jim Clark actually came and
join us out there the first person I
hired was Alvy Ray Smith it became a
good partner and friend and we hired in
the end up to 40 people doing R&D with
Alex Shore
supporting us but since I came out of
the University of Utah which was this
great environment what I wanted to do
was take the elements I learned that
environment and replicate them here mmm
now in truth in doing that I think I
made some mistakes I
had some theories about how to put
together group what are you 25 years old
at this time yeah something like that 25
years old and you're building a
40-person lab to do computer animation
somewhere out in Long Island cool it's
amazing so it was a great opportunity
and I'm grateful for that opportunity
right but we kept pushing things but one
thing we did which was not obvious to
people is had to do with our publishing
explain so there were other people who
also had the dream of making a movie so
when I graduated from school the reason
I couldn't get a job other places was as
I said the long-term goal is to make a
movie a computer animated computer
animated movie and the places where I'd
qualified like universities like they
couldn't see why they would hire
somebody to do research and making
movies right so that's why I ended up
originally in Massachusetts and then a
New York Tech because New York Tech
would support it but there were other
people who have the same dream and I
knew them all but their point of view
was if I develop a secret I don't want
others to know it because I need every
advantage I have as I'm marched toward
this goal right so I took the opposite
approach we are so far away from the
goal that the ideas actually aren't that
important because they'll get bypassed
and discover along the way so by
publishing everything we discovered hmm
we became completely engaged in a
broader community and because we
published and engaged then we hired the
best people ah the smart people were
drawn it was a honeypot
there's a honeypot strategy yeah and we
maintain it to this day went from there
to Lucasfilm to Pixar yeah and we
publish everything because others are
gonna discover